hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play in diff'ent
say
Elia Falls I all de founds I don't know
how to pronounce that but it looks like
a very very well made game because look
at this whoosh it's got one of these
interactive main menus which I really
like
I think his mate on the entity engine
and it's supposed to be really scary so
let's give it a try I was contacted by a
middle-aged woman mrs. Katherine ILDA
Falls to go to our house where she has
spent her childhood to fetch a very
important will and testament the will
and testament all I know is that her
father mr. Ildefonso
the owner committed suicide in this
house a servant was found dead strangled
and his wife and two children had ran
away and disappeared
wait his wife wait what about where her
father I'm wait the house was
transformed into a block of flats and
ever since no one could stay in and much
longer because of the screaming and
crying people heard all the time I'll
try to do my best to find that we'll
wait a minute so it's her father or her
as her father but her father committed
suicide and his wife and two children
disappeared but wouldn't that make her
one of them I don't know okay anyway so
this looks nice so FAR's what's that
what did I just do I didn't think I
would actually go anywhere so this
appears to be a multi-tiered room I have
a flare slit and I will be looking at
the fuse box
no fuse box is dead it looks quite nice
it's been a lot of work put into this I
can tell I do appreciate that I am also
really tall thinking that my head's
about to scrape that blue hello nice
light lens flare it also makes us this
game makes it seem like this guy's drunk
when he's walking but I guess that's
supposed to be why is there a chair in
here with the doily somebody sitting
there watching him is that for the
bathroom attendant on this one bathroom
with no sink
yeah whatever I will stop questioning
game design logic can't go on that one
seems to be locked
Oh what is this well there be a fridge
in a little alcove here this house
doesn't make sense
I already feel uneasy unless that's how
houses were designed wherever this is
hello this is outside a little walled
garden here this also does not make much
sense but whatever jump on it okay looks
like that could be broken what is this
we were cooling dinner for our masters
when we heard the mistress saying let's
go away children I've got everything
packed this is strange
I'd better keep this to myself probably
a bad idea so I don't know what's in
this house like diabolical what's that
on the top of my head is that my hat or
is that just by gigantic forehead that's
peering over everything I see man look
at my feet was I'm just a gangly
misshapen I am the monster hey hey hey
yeah okay I will freak out when I see
some unsuspecting victims no I mean
diabolical entities so don't know what I
was looking for and there there was some
sort of crack do jimal what's it that I
could have I don't know hammered out
this might be a bigger game than I had
previously anticipated whoa whoa oh this
guy must be either drunk or really high
cuz he is wobbling all over the place
click legally legally nothing there
hello who's awaiting me in the darkness
I heard that nothing too creepy so far
what that wait a minute but this is the
only way to go yes unless I can call out
the front door and never come back
Oh as always if you want to play this
for yourself just check out the link in
the description it's totally free for
high production quality it's pretty free
it's pretty free it's it's extremely
free I go home wait this was the only
way I could go and I just went in here
there was nothing here unless I was
willing to find like a key or something
oh god not a key hunt again
I hate hunting for keys died pain in the
ass I tried this did not work I can't
run Oh huh there must've been a key to
sitting like maybe in the toilet let me
get knee-deep in the bill wide that
closed on me huh door stop being so
haunted and squeaky I don't see anything
there's something in there I could go
down there if I could just get this door
open but I cannot that looks like a
thing that actually looks like the other
thing that was over there maybe I could
find a way and through here I can't I
can crouch okay so these are blocking my
way I can't go in there
is there any way that I can pounce stiff
aren't you good come up town Street no
apparently not maybe if I crouch and
interact with the thingamabob err I
could go through here come on open up
your [ __ ] I can't pouch
oh god it's I want you I can't yump
ether I can't yump yeah that's just
uh-huh ah nothing
yes how did I get you up in huh stop
coughing ah
God well this is not working this is a
bunch of crap hello doggie I hear you
uh-huh I'm a big gangly monster and I
can't get this open
no matter how hard I try what the [ __ ]
what am I supposed to do here this turn
America in advance
is there a hammer in this tool box or
something I'm at a complete loss
this doesn't make it whoa found a key
yeah I found a key now does it open this
or well I didn't even see a key I did
not see a key I just grabbed a key so it
doesn't open that and I am so slow so
I'm only assuming that it opens one of
the upstairs doors that was a long way
to go for that key and that was him I
didn't even see a key I just clicked on
it I'm lucky I would have been wandering
these halls for hours if I didn't want
to check this door first okay not to
that door man I would have but I
seriously would have been wandering for
hours if I did not find that key ah shut
up man just to inhale that asbestos and
toughen up you a little baby girl no
tolerance for the weakness in mother
gosh I you would be killed along with
the rest of them no potatoes for you
point is Irish no well that better loves
Russians like their potatoes vodka isn't
made from potatoes correct not that one
chickadee Judicature did I see a shadow
did I have a big tall hat I do that's my
hands not forehead ha ha I'm not some
big freak there we go
finally let's get to some diabolical
entities cuz so far it has been not
scary hey there hello what is that it's
like a drop-off or just some weird
little small tidy room well how'd you
even need a door there the design of
this house is very questionable um blood
on the mirror not scary
hmmm ah another journal entry let's read
it I was never happy with his house in
the first place released it was the
center of the city the mark was near the
theater too
but the noises upstairs were very
unbearable one night I heard a scream so
loud in terrifying that I had never
heard before it was very scary oh oh it
was very scary
Oh much like the rest of this house Oh
what was that hurt um they got swept
it's like a scream started and then it
got cut off
I saw me and my big gangly appearance
okay
nothing so far weird pieces of wood
blocking up the way this is terrible
does why's our fridge here of all places
to put a fridge this is not the best
okay nothing so far
I hear that hello somebody out there
bathroom maybe what's going on now
whew physics yay I guess but I didn't
find anything is there gonna be another
did I do that I did I did that no big
deal I did that yeah I did that I did
that I hear you where is you you in here
this weird room here oh there's a back
area here okay I didn't see that before
gotcha hello can I get through there no
so I'm over here new ah wha nothing in
there is there anything in there no I
didn't know you could open those I've
been to a bunch of drawers and they
didn't do that maybe I miss something
else I wouldn't be surprised like the
clues are so small I'm not surprised if
I haven't overlooked something
mmm oh come on really I can't get
through there fine
you don't know nothin about birthin no
babies isn't that gone with the wind
what do what is going on here Tom fell
okay so far like nothing has been like
scary scary has been weird I missed
something I must have missed some hello
need to find a will and testament but
there is no will and testament here I
must have missed something I must have
there's gotta be something a mess in
here Gersh turn it like this isn't this
known hello ah oh [ __ ] dude stop
coughing man you're scaring me that
cough was scarier than anything that's
in this house
all right I'm there's nothing here
though just a whole lot of nothing I'm
hearing strange noises but I'm going
back and forth in the house and there's
just nothing to show for it but this
clock I didn't look at this clock it's
making a lot of noise but doing a lot of
nothing nope nothing again geez what am
I missing
what am I missing what am I missing
ah God physics
ermahgerd physics God my fervor um no no
no can't get through here I hear you but
you're not doing anything jump out at me
make a loud noise bang some windows slam
a door do some gosh hi
you gonna scare me cuz nothing else has
it's a balcony here but I just can't get
through to it
okay there's nothing here I'm out of
here
hi are you something can you scare me
please anything all right screw this I'm
out
there's nothing here there was nothing
there there's nothing there's old game
is it a bunch of nothing this is nothing
here we go down to apartment one I
checked every corner I did not find a
key I didn't find anything there was
nothing there was absolutely nothing
there's nothing there's nothing here
wait is the front door open now I hear
some there's nothing there's nothing
mama mama there's nothing I didn't find
a will and testament I didn't find
nothing god damn it I don't know oh no
man this game is supposed to be scary I
haven't found the scares I want to find
the scares I want a Joe goes to jump out
of me I want some Hammond who's highly
rated and I can see why for the design
of it but there did not a lot going on
and it's really hard to progress like
I'm I swear I've been clicking
everywhere I spammed a as I was going
through that entire top floor but I've
got nothing to show for it literally
nothing to show for it so I will revisit
this again if you guys can tell me what
I'm doing wrong if I overlook something
it must have been so small and minut
that I could I that that I couldn't have
possibly seen it just cuz this big hat
is blocking my view I'm so long and
gangly I have no arms I don't know as
far as I can tell this game seems
downright cheerful by my accounts so
tell me what to do tell me what I'm
doing wrong I would love to know what
I'm doing wrong here so all right that's
all the time I got for this one so thank
you all so much for watching
click the annotation for videos that
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video
Oh
Wow
bathroom
holy
I
okay